[Musique]
bonsoir de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les titres
nous recevrons sur ce plateau paul l'ata
guerra étudiants aiment de management il
est à l'origine avec d'autres étudiants
d'un forum de l'emploi qui se déroule
demain à l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines nous présentera son
projet et puis sur ce plateau si
bernadette gano elle est avec nous ce
soir pour nous présenter le festival
éclats de lumière qui se déroule à queue
en cours un festival qui aura lieu du 27
janvier au 2 février
nous débutons ce c'est huit invités avec
le forum de l'emploi qui se déroule
demain à duvet et ce qu à guyancourt
l'objectif organiser une rencontre avec
des étudiants en m1 et en m2 management
et des intervenants professionnels dont
thales et le groupe fasse c'est bien ça
c'était exactement ça bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi vous avez décidé de vous
mettre en place vous des étudiants je me
présente je m'appelle paul attiyah je
suis étudiant en master de management
stratégique et du changement à lui vécu
et dans le cadre de cette formation qui
est une formation pour laquelle on
étudie la conduite du changement et la
gestion des projets on a bon
créer un projet notre projet si le forum
des métiers d'accor et pourquoi c'est
cette volonté pourquoi ce choix en fait
de ce forum là parce qu'en fait nous on
est étudiant et on voudrait se
rapprocher enfin créer une relation des
rencontres entre des professionnels et
des étudiants de m1 pour la première
partie du forum donc il y aura lieu la
matinée et pour l'après midi ce sera
entre seulement les masters de dons dans
mon master et des anciens de mon master
2 en fait pour voir qu'est ce qu'ils
sont devenus en fait d'accord est-ce que
vous pouvez un peu plus nous détailler
la matinée qu'est-ce que les m1 vont à
boire en plus d'argent que ce sera les
mains management de l'ue vs qu ils vont
rencontrer des anciens aiment et c'est
donc des anciens de mon master et des
professionnels qui n'ont pas de rapport
a priori avec ma formation donc comme
vous l'avez dit il y aura des personnes
de thales du groupe saur et aussi de la
face la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion des yvelines que vous
connaissez d'oise yvelines seulement
très bien donc on aura sur son
représentant qui sera là et en fait ça
permettra aux étudiants d'échanger avec
ces personnes de voir qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent faire et pourquoi pas trouver un
stage ou même plus si ça se passe bien
et pour l'après midi c'est plus les m2
qui sont mis en avant
c'est ça c'est ça fait ça ce sera aller
m2 en fait on va on va avoir des anciens
de ma formation et ont ils vont venir
nous expliquer leur parcours qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait après la sortie de la
fac
qu'est ce qu'ils sont devenus en fait
pour nous montrer un peu ce à quoi on
peut espérer être plus tard c'est
important de créer un lien aujourd'hui
avec le monde de l'entreprise s'est pas
assez fait non je pense que c'est
important surtout que là en fait on
essayait vraiment de faire du local en
fait on essayait de prendre des masters
des étudiants qui sont vraiment dans des
entreprises qui sont proches de notre
université pour vraiment renforcer
encore plus ce lien on a aussi le groupe
à l'umih qui nous aident à créer un
ancien un groupe des andes et ancien
mais c'est donc un groupe de réseaux
pour vraiment avoir cette notion de
réseau à être plus proche des
entreprises alors des entreprises et à
des démarches et oui comment il
ont pris cet événement eh ben on en est
pas mal d'entreprises qui étaient
motivés donc on a d'abord commencé par
nos cercles d'amis en fait c'était
beaucoup plus simple c'est quand vous
connaissez un quelqu'un qui travaille
dans six entreprises au plus simple mais
ouais comme tout événement on a aussi
des des déconvenues ont des personnes
qui nous on m'a dit non qui nous ont
lâchés donc on a dû continuer persévérer
pour avoir un nombre suffisant de
l'intervenant pour ceux qui ont accepté
que pourquoi ils ont accepté qu est-ce
qui vous ont dit c'était un besoin aussi
pour eux d'aller vers vous oui oui bah
parce qu'il y en a qui recherche des
stagiaires en fait donc ils sont tout
autant l'intéressé que nous et comme je
vous dis on a à peu près la moitié c'est
des anciens msc qui sont en poste dans
les entreprises et donc ils sont un peu
content de les redonner le de ce qu'on a
reçu en fait
et eux alors qu'est-ce qui vous disent
du monde de l'entreprise de pièces qui
vont vous apporter eh bien ils nous
disent que notre formation déjà elle est
allée très bien valorisé et qu'on
recherche des personnes comme nous donc
on est content puisque ont un diplôme
qui est en phase avec ce que recherchent
les entreprises et donc et qu'on voit
normalement facilement s'insérer dans le
monde de l'emploi
cette proposition en fait de faire cet
événement j'imagine que ça enrichit un
petit peu plus la formation c'était
compliqué pour les m1 de trouver des
stages par exemple là ça va pouvoir ça
va pouvoir les aider c'est pas évident
parce que souvent il y en a pour qui si
le premier stage en m1 est donc faux on
connait pas encore trop les démarches
donc là ça va vraiment permettre de
faciliter de faire des contacts en fait
permettre au m1 d'augmenter leurs
réseaux de l'élargir vous avez été
accompagnés de vos professeurs j'imagine
oui on a reçu tout leur soutien ainsi
que d'autres membres de deluz vs cul
pour nous aider pour la location de la
salle
l'îlot colis table on pourra acheter la
nourriture parce qu'il y aura plus de
pardon il y aura plusieurs collation
lors de cette journée
bon à savoir et au niveau des
entreprises est ce que vous pouvez me
les lister toutes celles qui seront
présentes
demain oui on aura entre autres donc
thales le groupe sauf le groupe saur
parlons talentsoft on aura donc la face
et on aura aussi des personnes qui sont
entrepreneurs qui ont leur propre
entreprise ça à table sur quel type
d'emploi par exemple
alors lille et fonction justement un
joli mais ça vient me rappeler cela pour
vous relancer les fonctions ses
fonctions rh fonction de conseil
marketing entrepreneuriat donc ça couvre
un large spectre de deux fonctions
auxquelles les étudiants peuvent
postuler
possibilité aussi d'avoir sur son cv une
expérience en plus
ensuite à déclasser stage et pour les m2
est ce que ça va leur permettre d'être
recruter plus facilement derrière on
sait que c'est compliqué le monde du
travail quand on sort des études comme
ça oui parce qu'on a beaucoup de
d'anciens m2m et c'est donc ma formation
qui nous disent si vous avez besoin d'un
travail contactez nous on envoie votre
cv nos entreprises recherchent des gens
comme vous qui a vraiment se résout qui
s'est mis en place donc notamment une
grâce au groupe à l'umih et donc ça aide
beaucoup
on a vraiment on part confiant monde du
travail
vous partez confiant alors tout toutes
ces personnes qui ont déjà validé leur
diplôme qui ensuite reviennent vous avez
un petit bouquin avec tous les
renseignements laon numéro il ya il ya
un suivi après sept journées
oui il ya un an qu'un autre groupe à moi
si le groupe futur donc il doit
organiser le forum des métiers notre
groupe qui s'appelle le groupe à l'umih
et hu doivent s'occuper du réseau de
lancer de les anciens étudiants et on a
donc une plateforme sur le site internet
qui met en lien les anciens étudiants et
nous les étudiants actuels
vous êtes combien alors sur ses anciens
étudiants venant sur à préparer le forum
des métiers forum on aime on ne compte
dans mon groupe on est 5
on travaille avec deux autres groupes
dont coût total on est dix sept
personnes et donc en plus de devoir
gérer le le forum on doit aussi gérer
donc la coordination avec les deux
groupes
j'imagine que c'est déjà un emploi avant
l'heure
exactement alors ça s'est passé comment
c'était compliqué oui fouette métiers
des magnifiques notamment au niveau de
la coordination
mais à force d'acharnement et de
motivation finir toujours par arriver ce
qu'on veut alors ça sera quoi votre
dernière phrase va ma dernière phrase
c'est
ce sera à tous les étudiants de venir
voir enfin tous les yeux qu'on a convié
de venir voir parce que je pense que
vraiment ça peut les aider pour leur
futur et bien je vous remercie
merci à vous on passe maintenant au
festival d'art sacré organisé du 27
janvier au 2 février ou au cap saint
jacques à guyancourt c'est la deuxième
édition du festival
le premier ayant eu lieu il ya deux ans
maintenant bonjour bernadette gano
cordes je vous êtes coordinatrice du
festival éclats de lumière
je suis pas seul je suis excusé j'ai une
voix qui défaillent aujourd'hui donc je
ne suis pas seul je savais que marie
pierre qui ne peut pas être là
aujourd'hui et toute une petite équipe
on est 6 pour l'instant et des bénévoles
nous sommes tous bénévoles nous aide
beaucoup de personnes autour de nous
pour nous aider techniquement
quelquefois montée et éventuellement des
installations des micros des ordinateurs
bref tout ce qui peut se mettre en place
pour accueillir nos artistes
alors dites moi un peu plus sur ce
festival donc c'est la deuxième édition
effectivement festival éclats de lumière
alors pourquoi et que la lumière parce
que pendant cette période de l'année on
est un petit peu morose la lumière
maintenant sa sacro un petit peu mais
enfin en règle générale c'est quand même
des gens nés un peu un peu tristounette
et on s'est dit que ça correspondait
vraiment à ce que nous nous vivions sur
le plan de notre de notre communauté
chrétienne
c'est à dire que nous allons célébrer la
présentation du seigneur au temple c'est
dire la chandeleur de 2 février
et c'est la fête de la lumière par
excellence nous on est très en lien avec
un autre festival de la lumière qui le
festival de libourne avec lequel on
entretient d'excellentes relations
et on s'est dit que effectivement cette
lumière et bien nous avions la mission
quelque sorte de la deûle à refléter
nous aussi et de la réflecteurs par le
bo par le sacré par tous qui nous nous
tirent vers le haut un petit peu des
bonnes de choix de et que ces éclats de
lumière cette lumière pardon se décliner
en éclat que nous étions pour
transmettre à d'autres personnes parce
que tout ce qui est beau alors c'est le
lien victimes entre l'art la culture et
la foi qui sous tend ce festival et qui
nous qui nous mène qui nous pousse en
avant alors c'est la deuxième édition
deuxième édition
alors qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver de
nouveau c'était de nouveau alors nous
n'aurons pas d'expositions de peinture
comme c'est vrai 2015 mais en 2018 ou
2019 nous recommençons certainement car
c'était un franc succès ça nous a été
demandé mais bon cette année c'est un
peu difficile organisé par contre nous
avons du théâtre on attend avec gérard
rouzier qui est seul sur pas de vrai nom
seul parce qu'il est accompagné à la
clarinette klezmer c'est compliqué c'est
qu'une énorme clarinette basse le
carrosse bako joue avec beaucoup de
vraiment de savoir faire et donc lui va
nous présenter trois personnages de la
bible dans leur découverte d'un chemin
nouveau pour eux et il le fait avec
beaucoup d'émotion d'humour d'humanité
aussi change de vêtements il se démène
en fermant ces cétacés
c'est vraiment entraînant et très
touchant
car ce matin j'étais des preuves nous
sommes peut-être tous les pr à nous de
voir quels chemins nous si long
musée cause la musique avec des petits
chanteurs les petits chanteurs de saint
françois de versailles qui vont nous
interpréter alors encore des noëls
puisque finalement traditionnellement on
est dans la période de noël jusqu'au 2
février un accord donc il nous offre ces
chants de noël des carreaux l'onglet est
également de la musique baroque
française
donc voilà sous la direction musicale de
gaëtan jarry je crois qu'ils sont très
appréciés dans la région je les ai vu
passer dans différents lieux juste avant
noël et juste après noël
donc qu'ils rient chine c'est une grosse
organisation quand même nom
d'entraînement a vraiment non non c'est
très agréable
c'est sur une semaine sur une semaine
c'est très très agréable d'accueillir
tous ces artistes et on entre at il
vraiment des liens que je n'aurais
jamais imaginé avant c'est très
sympathique de change était alors nous
avons également dû un couple musical
biblique qui en fait en ce moment a lieu
la comédie musicale toby et sarah qui
est donné dans différents endroits
théâtre des environs je crois que moi je
boulogne billancourt je crois que ça ira
imad maison fait donc à les différents
endroits
elle a beaucoup de succès est donc l'un
nous n'aurons pas la comédie musicale
mais nous aurons le conte musical tiré
de cette cette comédie donc à deux voix
avec etienne et jocelyne tarnos qui
alterneront avec du chant puisque
etienne et compositeur chanteur et donc
il nous interprétera des extraits de la
comédie musicale alors une première
édition
vous avez reçu combien de personnes à
peu près ça avait bien fonctionné allait
bien fonctionnel vous dire combien de
personnes c'est assez difficile nous
avions eu du théâtre avec
soeur emmanuelle caisse yann à l'arrivée
une centaine de personnes et puis après
peut vous dire cinquante personnes un
côté 30 de l'autre rive et les ateliers
il veut et par contre l'exposition
peinture énormément de monde on vous a
redemandé où vous à re sollicité
derrière pour faire une deuxième édition
alors on nous a fait surtout confiance
vous savez il faut pas mal de temps
effectivement pour qu'un festival puisse
vraiment être connus le festival de
libourne fête ses 10 ans et son
organisatrice m'a dit qu'il a fallu
presque dix ans pour vraiment être tout
à fait connu et vous êtes combien
racontez moi pour faire venir les
artistes n'auront pas ce façon ici sur
les stands on espère bien étoffer notre
équipe ce n'est pas très difficile vous
savez il est vraiment énormément de
propositions qui sont faites dans le
théâtre chrétien ou pas chrétien mais
qui du moins à peine le beau le kin one
hakiki susciter une réflexion
spirituelle
alors la première fois nous avions fait
venir
donc c'est françois sur ios dans soeur
emmanuelle
il y en a c'est une qu'est ce que je
veux dire croyants ou non croyants
n'importe qui peut voir et donc si le
but c'est que ce festival s'adresse à
tout le monde
eh bien merci merci d'être venu sur le
plateau
c'est la force de ce sept huit invités
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]